Musik Mein Name ist Stefan, das Fun steht für Spaß, wir sind im Studio und wir geben jetzt Gas. Mein Name ist Florentin Will, zur Erinnerung, und das wird die beste Folge seit Folge, keine Zahl reimt sich auf Erinnerung, sorry, ich habe mir eigentlich so eine Strasse gebaut, dass ich dachte, gut, da komme ich jetzt gut weiter von da, aber es reint sich tatsächlich keine Zahl.
Mein Name ist Stefan, ich baue die Strasse. Wir sind hier nicht zu eurer Strafe, denn wir haben was dabei für euch vorbereitet.
Egal, ob es euch gefällt, wir werden eine richtig geile Zeiter.
Der Brake.
Das ist auch nur eine klassische Figur, der Beatboxer, der es übertreibt.
Der hat vier, versucht vier Töne gleichzeitig. Double Bass vor allem auch.
Wicke, wicke, wicke, wicke, wicke, wicke, wicke, boom, tschak, boom.
Florandin, wie geht's dir? Was ist los? Wie war diese Woche?
Es ist echt ein bisschen arg dunkel hier, ist es nicht sonst heller?
Ja, du kannst da nämlich noch eine Lampe andrücken im Flure. Im Flure? Dann öffnen wir die Türe zur Flure. Franziskarr, Karoline Reiber, Barbara, fährt mit einem Rhönrad durch den Rhein. Barbara reist Richtung Regensburg. Buongiorno, Senora, bella donna andiamo. Buongiornono Senora. Das sind die Folgen, wo man denkt, man fühlt sich gerade so aufgedreht und geil und cool und es ist lustig alles. Wenn man die nachher schneidet, denkt man, oh fuck, warum habt ihr dich ein bisschen lang zurückgeschaltet. Und es ist eigentlich nur über Spielen, das wir überhaupt nichts zu sagen haben, denn wir sind heute wieder hier in unserem Studio mit Stefan Titzel. Und vor dem Willen. Dankeschön, dankeschön, dankeschön. Titzel mein Name. Wir haben heute eine Pickebacke vor der Sendung für euch vorbereitet. Wir haben noch nie so viel vorbereitet. Wir haben, das ist echt so. Wir gehen schwanger heute, würde ich sagen. Wir befinden uns im achten Monat. Wir sind kurz vor der Entbindung und wir haben heute alles nochmal reingesteckt, was wir haben und alles ist da. Die Metapher bricht einfach in sich zusammen. Und alles bricht einfach in sich zusammen. Wir haben, um einfach mal ein bisschen zu teasen, wir machen heute nur wirklich eine... Wir hauen einen Megakommentar raus, den ihr für uns hinterlassen habt. Der beste Kommentar aller Zeiten, meiner Meinung nach. Eine neue Rubrik, der Kommentar der Woche. Das sind zwei unterschiedliche Dinge. Und wir haben tatsächlich wieder eine Menge Kindergeschichten von euch bekommen, auf die wir heute mal ein bisschen eingehen. Das heisst, ihr könnt... Was heisst wieder? Wir haben aber die ganze Zeit schon sehr viele Kindergeschichten bekommen und ich habe auch wieder welche mitgebracht.
Das heißt, ihr könnt euch heute wieder auf eine, wie gesagt, Picke, Packe, wir fangen einfach nochmal an,
weil das hat überhaupt keinen Sinn ergeben von vorne bis hinten und ich habe hier auch ständig Störgeräusche drin. Aber zum Thema, Leute haben ja schon gefragt, wann wir mal Jan Böhrmann einladen. Nur kurze Info, Jan Böhrmann befindet sich momentan im Raum nebenan, wo der Tisch steht, den wir normalerweise zur Aufnahme verwenden. Und wir haben uns es nicht getraut, in den Raum zu gehen, um den Tisch zu holen. Also so viel zum Thema. Folge 50, Freude auf Jan Böhrmann. So viel zu dem TH1 kommt Jan Böhmer in die Folge. Wir haben wirklich mörderische Angst vor diesem Menschen. Aber unbegründet. Wir haben einfach nur wahnsinnigen Respekt.
Gut, manchmal lauft er bei einer Peitsch hinter uns her und verprügelt uns mit seinem Schlagring, den er sich jetzt vorgestern gekauft hat. Aber auf der anderen Seite, eigentlich ist die Angst unbegründet, weil wir sind wahnsinnige Schisser und wir glauben, dass wir nicht abliefern können. Nee. Wir glauben sogar, dass wir noch niemals die Zeit überbrücken können, wo wir den Tisch klauen, dass wir in dieser Zeit nicht mehr abliefern können. Ja, dass wenn er irgendeinen Gag macht, wir einfach nicht reagieren können. Wir sind ja immer nur so stark wie unser schwächstes Glied. Also lege ich noch ein bisschen zu. Und einfach wenn, glaube ich, naja, es ist halt wieder dieses hübsche Frauen-Ding, wenn jemand total Lustiges im Raum ist, ist man plötzlich nicht mehr. Wir fangen nochmal neu von vorne an. Tag drei. Die Podcast-Ufo-Anfang-Folge. Bild euren besten Anfang.
War es die Nummer 1? Hier nochmal ein kleiner Recap. Die Nummer 1? Wer die? 0-1 für Anfang Nummer 1. Amo! Anfang Nummer 2? Stefan, ich habe dir gesagt, wir hauen die Kabel von unten! Anfang Nummer 3? Ich liebe dich! Anfang Nummer 4? Ja, wir sind ja total narzisstische Typen, ne, bei uns, weil wir machen ja den Podcast nur, weil wir gitarren.
Anfang Nummer fünf, it's a hard knock life for us.
Anfang Nummer sechs, all the single ladies, all the single ladies.
Anfang Nummer sechs, jetzt müssen wir Gitarrenmusik einfügen.
Wählen sie die, 09 für, ganz kurz, so viel zum Thema Jan Böbermann einladen.
Das heißt, Wählen Sie die 0,9 für, ganz kurz so viel zum Thema Jan Böbermann einladen, das haben ein paar Leute in den Kommentaren geschrieben, wir sollen Jan Böbermann einladen, folgendes ist gerade der Sachverhalt. Wählen Sie die 10 für oder die 11 für, wann wollen wir eigentlich mal wieder Eis verkaufen?
Das Tolle ist, du kannst nicht schneiden, weil dann die Zahlen keinen Sinn mehr ergeben, ausser du schneidest total gut oder wählst die Nummer 12, geschnitten wegen Inhalt. Ja und jetzt müssen die Zuschauer abstimmen oder wie soll das jetzt funktionieren? Wir machen jetzt kurz hier eine Pause von fünf Minuten, damit die Zuschauer, wenn sie sich das anhören, Zeit haben für uns anzurufen.
Äh, nee, eine Spende. Sie können uns spenden und sie können in Spendenbetreff A, B, C, D, je nachdem bis vierzehnten halt eingeben. Bis dem vierzehnten Buchstaben ins Alphabet. Genau. Und immer alle Spenden ab zwei Euro zählen und dann schneiden wir den Anfang, der euch am liebsten, am besten gefallen hat, an die nächste Folge dran. Oder wir machen es folgendes, unser Social Media Manager erklärt es euch einfach nochmal, ja, was wollt ihr, wollt ihr ein Like für ein Eis haben, für ein Like gibt es ein Eis. Die Schnitten wegen Hörspiel. Wir waren noch nie so gut vorbereitet, das haben wir schon ein paar Mal gesagt, ich weiß nicht genau, wir haben schon sehr viele Anfänge aufgenommen und ich weiß nicht genau, ich habe ein bisschen den Überblick verloren. Deswegen sagen wir jetzt alles nochmal. Wir haben nur kein Sendungsthema, das ist immer ein bisschen problematisch. Ja gut, aber im Nachhinein ist es uns noch immer, es hätte noch immer Jodt gegangen, wie man hier in Köln sagt. Der Dom steht noch. Das geht sich schon aus, weißt du, wir müssen einfach anfangen, das geht sich schon aus. Du bist auf Zack, der Florent ist auf Zack. Ich bin heute richtig auf Zack. Aber wir haben tatsächlich viele Einsendungen von euch bekommen,
vielen Dank nach Dahmer für die ganzen Kindergeschichten.
Kinder. Und gehen wir heute einfach mal ein paar aufreisen,
weil heute werden einfach ein paar Jungfernhäutchen aufgerissen.
Herr auf, erst kurz.
Und wir holen eure Kindheit nochmal zum Vorschein.
Und das wird bestimmt richtig lustig.
Stefan hat natürlich auch noch ein paar ausgekramen.
Ich habe noch ein paar Geschichten gefunden,
in meinem unerschöpflichen Leichtsinn an geschriebenen Dingen,
aus meiner Vergangenheit. Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, ich habe nicht mit so vielen Geschichten gerechnet. Ich glaube, es waren auch sehr wenig ausgedachte Sachen dabei, weil die meisten haben halt Beweisfotos mitgeschickt gleich. Aber ich glaube, es ist sehr schwer, wie ein Kind zu schreiben, also das dann nochmal so umzuformulieren. Das ist ja auch das Tolle an dieser Rubrik, die ich mir ausgedacht habe, dass man ja die Unterschiede zwischen wie ein Mann, ein wachsen Mensch. Das war deine Idee, genau wie der Name des Podcasts, genau wie mein Name war auch deine Idee. Ey, Name war meine Idee. Nein. Doch, natürlich war Podcast. Auf gar keinen Fall. Alter, jetzt nicht diese scheiß Diskussion wieder. Ich habe keinen Bock darauf. Ich weiß doch genau, wie wir hier in der Leihendecker drüben saßen, mit Essen vom Speisemeister. Vom Pizza-Ufo. Nee. Vom Pizza-Ufo. Und da habe ich gesagt, Podcast-Ufo wäre eine Idee. Nee, ich habe gesagt Podcast-Ufo. Du hast es nie gesagt. Wir haben gesagt Podcast-Torpedo oder das Podcast-U-Boot. Nein, Podcast-Torpedo war nie U-Boot. Doch, wir hatten immer Podcast-Torpedo, Podcast-U-Boot oder das Comedy-Shuttle, hatten wir auch mal kurz für fünf Minuten gebrainstompt. Aber relativ schnell ist es aufgefallen, wie es lächerlich ist. Nee, Podcast-Ufo ist meine Idee. Auf gar keinen Fall. Wobei, was dazu dafür sprechen würde, dass es deine Idee war, es ist halt Social Media mässig gedacht furchtbar. Wieso? Weil erstmal heisst diese Gewerkschaft, wo die ganzen Piloten jetzt anfangen zu streiken, heisst auch UFO, dann heisst ganz viele Verschwörungs-Podcasts, he Podcast-Ufo, Ufo-Podcast, whatever.
Aber ich mag es mal, wenn es im Namen schon einfach man weiss, worum es geht, was es für ein Medium ist.
Podcast-Ufo, weiss jeder, es ist ein Podcast.
Und ich finde es gut, dass man beim Namen eingeben schon Verwirrung, diese Methode der Verwirrung entgegenbekommt.
Ja, schon mal so ein angenehmes Gefühl der Verwirrung.
Man weiss schon, okay, anscheinend ist es nur jeder Podcast. Wo wir dann einfach direkt reingrätschen und wir dann einfach die weiteren Zutaten für diesen perfekten Verwirrungskoktel liefern. Wenn man heute bei Google, es war einmal vor langer, langer Zeit in einer weit entfernten Galaxis eingibt, kam heute dieser Fliegetext, dieser Durchs-Universum-Fliegetext, wo ich mich bis heute frage, wo kommt der eigentlich her? Also fliegt der da rum und andere Raumschiffe sehen den und müssen ausweichen? Da gibt es hundertprozentig auch irgendwo einen Gag, dass mal jemand gegen diese Texttafel geflogen hat. Ich finde, das ist keine gute Herangehensweise zu sagen, diesen Gag gibt es möglicherweise. Also wir sind schon zu einer neuen Stufe übergegangen. Wir sind vom Klauen mittlerweile übergegangen zu, wir sagen lieber gar nichts mehr, es könnte schon mal irgendwer gemacht haben. Das ist die falsche Herangehensweise. In letzter Zeit geht es mir häufiger so, dass ich mir einen Gag überlege und mir denke, hundertprozentig hat den schon mal jemand gemacht und ihn deswegen nicht veröffentliche.
Einfach aus Angst vor Diebstahl, weil er möchte nicht des Diebstahls bezichtigt werden. Ja, aber das ist Quatsch. Ja, das ist tatsächlich Quatsch. Wir haben jetzt beide das Buch gelesen. Ich bin jetzt endlich auf deinem Stand, intellektuell. Ich habe das Buch gelesen. Das einzige Buch, das ich gelesen habe, hast du jetzt auch gelesen. Ja, genau. Steel Like an Artist. Und da kommt ja auch ganz auf, da ist auf 278 Seiten beschrieben, dass man klauen sollte. Man sich ein gutes Gefühl anreden kann, dass man gerade was geklaut hat und dafür Geld bekommen hat. Es ist ein Buch für Künstler, um sich ein gutes Gefühl einzulesen, quasi. Dass man halt klauen kann, so viel man will, weil es gab eh alles schon mal und hey, so what, du bist eh immer dein eigener Typ und du willst es auch so formulieren, du willst es ja nicht so klauen sondern du willst es deinen wortschers anpassen und dann wird es automatisch zu deinem auch an der stelle sehr zu empfehlen die videodokumentationsreihe everything is a remix wo auch noch mal darauf eingegangen wird über urheberrecht und das eigentlich alles nur geklaut ist und bands von ihren bands mit denen sie zusammen touren eigentlich songs eins zu eins geklaut haben aber so so ist es nun mal, das Leben.
Kommen wir nun zu unserer ersten
Rubrik, die Anekdote der Woche.
Anekdote der
Woche. Oh stimmt, wir hatten ja mal
der Badass-Moment der Woche.
Tatsächlich machen wir
mal eine Rubrik mehr als einmal
und nämlich der Badass-Moment der Woche.
Wir hören nochmal den Jingle.
Badass!
Ja, come on.
Dope! Und zwar auf dem Weg hierhin heute ist es mir tatsächlich passiert, ich habe mir nämlich schön beim Lidl eine schöne Apfeltasche geholt zum Frühstück, einfach mal schön verzehrt to go. Und da hatte ich diese Packung in der Hand, habe die zusammengeknüllt zu so einer faustgrossen Knüllpackungsknüllung. Wird eh rausgeschnitten, merke ich jetzt schon, ist einfach jetzt schon klar.
Wenn du merkst, dass ich mit den Augenrolle, schon vorbei, gibt dir keine Mühe mehr.
Ja, man sieht schon, er ist schon zum Scherenmann geworden und dann bin ich auf so einen Mülleimer zugelaufen und als er noch so zwei, zweieinhalb, ich übertreibe, vier Meter weit weg war,
habe ich dann diese Tüte in den Mülleimer geworfen und dann stand direkt davor so ein Auto, das war so eineuzung war, und dann habe ich den in den Mülleimer geworfen und dann bin ich weitergegangen und habe ich gesehen, dass in einem Auto auf der Rückbank ein kleines Mädchen saß, das mich die ganze Zeit angeguckt hat und mich total mit grossen Augen angeguckt hat und er einfach so locker am Auto vorbeigegangen ist. Yeah, face, whoop, yeah, girl, ja, perfekt, aber naja. Ich habe neulich einen Badass-Moment gehabt, im positiven Sinne. Ich habe Menschen geholfen. Neben mir saß eine Frau in der U-Bahn, die ist dann weggegangen, um ihre Karte, es wird nicht besser, die war schon älter, um ihre Karte abzustellen und ist weggegangen, hat aber ihre Taschenleben belegen lassen und ich dachte mir, gut, ich greife nicht ein in die Geschehnisse der U-Bahn, ich bin so eine überstehende Distanz.
U-Bahn hat ihr eigenes Gesetz, der Kosmos U-Bahn.
Ich sage immer, man sollte da nicht zwischenfunken, life finds away. Okay, und dann kam letztendlich ein Mann, der, obwohl die Taschen da alle standen, sich da draufgesetzt hat, einfach den Platz neben mir.
Und ich habe gesagt, ich habe meine Stöpsel aus dem Ohr genommen, partizipiert, bin eingeschritten und habe gesagt, nein, gehen Sie bitte, hier sitzt schon jemand, woraufhin er gegangen ist. Und dann kam die Frau wieder und hat sich bedankt, durch die ganze Uhr hat sie mich bedankt und die Leute haben mich angeguckt und gedacht, wow, das ist der Held. Das war mein Badass-Moment der Woche. Wie fühlst du dich, dass du komplett normales menschliches Verhalten als den Badass-Moment der Woche verkaufst, Stefan?
Dass ich ein Schwächling bin. Ich bin, ähm, sorry, ich habe gerade eine sehr wichtige E-Mail bekommen. Ein Herz-Emoji. Manchmal ist das die wichtigste Nachricht. Wusstest du, dass der grüne Herz-Emoji Eifersuch? Er hat ihn wahrscheinlich. Haben wir schon mal. Also, ich habe tatsächlich auch im, ich sass im und so in Zweireihe und die Zweireihe neben mir saß auch eine junge Frau und ich glaube, sie hat versucht, mit mir zu flirten. Nein. Ich bin mir aber nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Den Mittelfinger zeigen ist nicht flirten. Ich möchte nur zeigen. Darauf hinweisen, dass du deine fucking Fresse halten solltest, ist auch kein Flirten. Ja, ich möchte nur erzählen, wie ich es geschafft habe, diesen Flirt massiv kompetent einfach im Keim zu ersticken. Und zwar da saß ich im ICE und dann... Ja, du bist auch nicht müde, das zu erwähnen, wie du im ICE. Mein Gott, ich versuche ein Bild zu malen. Ja, entschuldige. Mein Gott, ich saß im ICE, die wunderschöne Landschaft Nordrhein-Westfalen zog in einer blitzschnellen Geschwindigkeit neben mir hervor. Das Bild warzerrt, eine Giraffe stand einfach. Die Bäume verschwammen zu einem
abstrakten Strudel von Emotionen
und Natur. Und dann
kam der Ruf der Natur, ich musste auf die Toilette
gehen und ich nehme immer meinen Laptop mit auf die Toilette.
Und dann kam ich zurück
und sie hat das gesehen, dass ich mein Laptop
dabei hatte und meine so, ah, hast du versucht,
die Toilette zu hacken? Ah, hast du versucht, zu masturbieren?
Nein.
Sie hat gesagt, hast du versucht, die Toilette zu hacken? Und dann hat mich gesagt, nee, ich habe mir immer Angst, dass ihr geklaut wird. Sie war halt die Einzige, die neben mir sass. Und ich setze mich da hin und denke kurz nach so Tick-Tock so, oh shit, fuck, und sie einfach, okay, dann fick ich dich, ich weiß nicht. Ja, Moment, aber... Und wie machst du dann weiter, was ist das Follower? Erstmal wollte sie einen Gag machen offensichtlich. Ja, aber auch keinen schlechten. Aber du als Humor-Genius einfach die Wahrheit zu sagen. Ja. Natürlich auch so, ich mache beruflich was mit Comedy und ich will darauf nicht eingehen. Aber ich rechne nicht damit, dass Leute versuchen, lustig zu sind. Damit rechne ich einfach nicht. Und das kann einen wirklich manchmal hart treffen. Und dann sitzt du da und denkst, gibt es jetzt eine Möglichkeit, da nochmal darauf einzusteigen, so, vergiss es nochmal komplett, was ich gerade gesagt habe. Aber es ist auch nicht geil, es ist auch nicht cool, was sie gesagt hat. Ich finde es total cool, hallo. Ich glaube, mittlerweile will ich, dass es ein Flirtversuch war, weil es dieses Halbgare, dieses nicht ganz ausgereifte, dieses, ich muss auf Biegen und Brechen mit dir reden und sage deshalb an unfertigen Gedanken, sage ich dir. Ja, und vor allem sie hat das aufgegriffen, was tatsächlich ungewöhnlich in der Situation war, dass ich mit meinem Laptop aufs Klo gehe.
Vielleicht hat sie überlegt, ob sie den Porno-Gag machen will, wusste aber nicht, was ich für ein Typ bin und hat sich für die harmlosere Variante tun.
Ich fand den Gag auch nicht schlecht. Man muss ja erwähnen, sie war neun Jahre alt und ein bisschen beschädigt, körperlich beschädigt.
Ich hatte meine Schere nicht dabei.
Also die Geschichte ist komplett erfunden, ist so nicht passiert.
Ich finde es grossartig, wenn Frauen lange Haare haben, weil ich finde diese Symbolhaftigkeit in langen Haaren als Spam-Filter, kann man gut verstehen. Also es ist immer so ein Vorhang vor den Ohren. Und ich finde das ganz symbolisch eigentlich, sie werden sehr oft angequatscht von Typen, die irgendwas komische, moralische, verwerfliche Angebote machen. Aber Frauen haben immer so eine Art Spam-Filter. Die machen das auch automatisch, dass sie sich so die Haare vor die Ohren schieben, wenn sie nicht wieder reden wollen.
Und sie machen das zurück, wenn sie die Aufmerksamkeit.
Das ist gut.
Sie schieben sich diesen Spam-Filter weg, so wie zum Vorhang.
Flirtexperter Steffi Tingo.
Naja, kommen wir zu unserer neuen Rubrik, dem Kommentar der Woche.
Du verschluckst manchmal das R bei Rubrik.
Also du sagst ja auch, Entschuldigung, ich will nur, ich schlüpfe gerade nur in die, in die, äh,
Buongiorno Senora, perdona andiamo, ich schlüpfe gerade nur in der, in die Rolle unserer Hörer.
Tante Trude, Tanz mit Theo, Tango, Twist und Tarantella.
Tante Trude, Tanz mit Theo, Tango, Twist und Tarantella. Also, wir haben einen, wir kriegen jede Woche, wir machen mal so eine klassische Anmoderation.
Wir vom Podcast UFO kriegen jede Woche wunderbare Kommentare.
Aber nicht immer können wir da. Tante, Trude, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, Tante, und das Faxgerät. Und da kommen immer ganz tolle Kommentare. Und wir haben uns überlegt, warum, wir geben den Leuten nicht zurück.
Ich möchte ganz kurz, ich habe gerade eine Idee.
Ja.
Und ich will diese Idee nicht verschenken.
Und deswegen wollte ich kurz darauf eingehen.
Okay, dann machen wir das.
Ich will mein Festnetz loswerden zu Hause.
Ach, du warst noch ein Festnetz?
Ich habe nur ein Festnetz, weil ich habe das Internet, Entertain und Festnetz-Paket von der Telekom gekauft.
Hast du da einen Anrufbeantworter?
Ja, auch theoretisch.
Also was passiert, wenn man da jetzt anruft?
Ja, es klingelt und dann kommt ein Anrufbeantworter.
Ja, auch theoretisch. Was passiert, wenn man da jetzt anruft? Ja, es klingelt und dann kommt ein Anrufbeantworter. Und diese Nummer haben nur meine Eltern. Ich will wissen, was du für eine Anrufbeantworter ansprach hast. Ja, nicht ich. Wie, nicht du. Es kommt eine Frau, die sagt, sie ruft einen An bei 022 whatever. Von so einem Comedy Mastermind wie Steffi Tizipato. Du rennst echt auf, du runs out of names. Ja, ich habe keinen Namen mehr. Leute, falls ihr noch mal einen weiteren coolen Namen habt von Stefan Tingel, schickt sie mir bitte. Ich habe keine Ideen mehr, ich bin völlig leer. Jedenfalls, ich wollte dieses Paket abbestellen, aber du wirst das Festnetz nicht los. Also die schenken das mittlerweile, weil die, also ich glaube die einzigen, die sich noch zwanghaft ans Festnetz krallen, ist die Telekom selber. Also du kannst das, du kannst es nicht loswerden. Ich frage mich, warum? Also was haben die denn davon? Was ist denn das, das Ding? Also, also die ist ja auch wesentlich billiger als Handy. Ja, aber es war... Die krallen sich da dran, mit allen Mitteln halten die sich daran fest, wie so ein Kind, was man ins Bett zieht, weil es abends ins Bett muss oder weil es uns vergewaltigen will. Man zieht es ins Bett und es krallt sich doch so an Dinge, so an die letzten Möbelstücke im Raum irgendwie. Aber du hast trotzdem auch kein Kabel mehr, oder? An deinem festen Telefon. Also das ist dann so eine Dockingstation, wo du dann... Ja, ja, es ist schon doch dieses dicke Kabel drin, dieses längliche, dieses schmale Längliche. Nee, aber ich meine zwischen Hörerapparaten. Nein, natürlich nicht. Das ist schon sehr lang. Weil das fand ich immer toll. Und dann gab es auch Telefone, die ein ewig langes Ding hatten, wo man sich dachte, ja die Leute wollen wahrscheinlich durch die Gegend laufen, während sie reden. Aber Festnetztelefon, na ihr Kinder da draußen, ihr wisst ja gar nicht, wie das damals war. Warum das Festnetz heisst. Ja, wo man damals bei seinem Schwarm anrufen musste und dann geht die Mutter ran und man sagt, hallo ist die Carina zuhause, kann sie vielleicht rauskommen. kann sie vielleicht kurz rauskommen, oder was bei uns war, dass bei uns immer Hausleute angerufen haben für meinen Bruder, und mein Zimmer war im ersten Stock, mein Bruder war im dritten, im Keller empfangen, im fünften Stock, mit einem sehr hohen Haus gewonnen, sehr schmal, war im Keller gefangen, und wenn der keine Fischköpfe mehr hatte, dann wollte der, dann hat er Leute angerufen, um mir was zu essen zu bringen, und dann musste ich immer sagen, ja hallo, ist der Piep da? Und dann habe ich immer wirklich mich zurückgelehnt, Luft geholt und aus voller Kehle immer durch das gesamte Haus gebrüllt, damit er es hört und dann unten bei ihm sein Festnetz, damit er hochkommen konnte. Ich habe gerade gedacht, ich bin so lustig, wenn dein Bruder wirklich Piep hieß. So, dass immer alle denken, warum piept der das jetzt? Oh, glaub der wirklich, juckt uns wieder, wie sein Bruder heisst und er heisst einfach Piep. Ja, wir drei Brüder, Piep, Pocke und Pong, die waren die würdeste Familie. Und Florian Zine, was immer schon ein bisschen der Außenseite. Ein bisschen komisch, ja. Wir waren stehen geblieben bei unserer neuen tollen Rubrik Wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, wah, dingelilingeling, der das Kommentar der Woche. Heute mal nicht von Stefan Schwier, sondern ein anderer hat sich durchgesetzt an den Olymp unserer Kommentatoren, und zwar Lump.
Ganz kurz, Lump. Man muss dazu sagen, du wirst ihn gleich vorlesen.
Ich hoffe, mal gucken, wie viele Unterbringungen kommen.
Ich finde, es ist der mit Abstand beste Kommentar oi, oi, oi, oi, Wirklich toll. Warum? Ja, das würde ich gerne nachher analysieren. Ich würde dich bitten, ihn jetzt mal kurz vorzutragen. Lump schrieb folgenden Kommentar. Auch teuer Name schon, Lump. Folge Donny O'Sullivan schrieb er, seit der Folge Hass dabei und diese hat mir bisher am besten gefallen. Und jetzt kommt. Insgesamt sehr lustiger Podcast, mehr aber auch nicht. Erstmal vielen Dank an Lumpf für das Kompliment, wir freuen uns sehr, aber das ist schon ganz geil, zu sagen, sehr lustiger Podcast, mehr aber auch nicht. Das ist genau so, als würde man sagen, Schatz, ich liebe dich sehr, mehr aber auch nicht. Das ist ein tolles Sportwagen, mit allem, was ich brauche, mehr aber auch nicht. Ja, genau, es war eine eins, aber mehr auch nicht. Volle Punktzahl, aber mehr halt nicht. Das ist ausgedacht. Das ist nämlich so gut. Loben, aber trotzdem ein schlechtes Gefühl machen, unerschwellig, mit dem Selbstbewusstsein noch eins auswischen irgendwie. Ja, vor allem ist es so schön, weil er impliziert ja, dass es irgendwelche mystischen, transzendenten Qualitäten gibt, die wir nicht erfüllen. Die wir nicht kennen auch. Was ist das denn? In welchen Sphären lebt dieser Lump? Was führt der für ein Leben, dass er Dinge erfahren und fassen kann, auf die wir gar nicht kommen? Das ist ja fantastisch. Also erstmal natürlich ein gutes T-Shirt-Motiv, lustiger Podcast, mehr aber auch nicht. Ja, ein bisschen arrogant. Oder auch nicht. Ja, oder einfach so ein Tattoo. Stefan, Titze, cooler Typ, mehr aber auch nicht. Ich finde das so lustig. Das ist unfassbar. Was kann denn noch? ich will wissen, Lumpi, komm mal vorbei, ich will wissen, was siehst du denn noch, was kann da noch sein? Das ist schon geil, einfach Bestnote, aber mehr auch nicht, das ist so wirklich diese Top-Arroganz, einfach es war so gut es geht, aber es war mir immer noch nicht gut genug, das ist einfach eine geile Einstellung, Lump will das Maximum, er will die 110%, er will einfach bis zum 8%. Ich glaube glaube, Lump ist auch einer von denen, die nie zufrieden sind, die immer ein bisschen mehr wollen, die nie sich komplett zur Ruhe legen können. Finde ich super. Die immer fragen, da geht doch noch mehr Leute. Mich hat der Kommentar motiviert. Man sagt ja auch, in dem tollen Film Whiplash TM, sagt man, der einzige Film, den er gesehen hat. Nein, sagt, Jake is just kidding Simmons, sagtding Simmons sagt. Wow, der war aber nicht spontan, oder? Tatsächlich. Der hat gesagt, ich schwöre dir, es geht nicht. Der hat nämlich gesagt, dass... J.K. Joking Rowling wurde 100% schon mal gemacht. Just Kidding Rowling kann sein. Just Kidding 100%. Oh, Jesus, sein Laptop ist runtergefallen. Oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott. Oh nein. Geht alles noch. Oh, das hat jetzt gerade richtig weh getan. Spiegelneuronen greifen anscheinend auch bei Laptops. Ja, und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen. Ich will nicht, dass du jetzt den Credit für diesen guten Witz bekommst. Den hat hundertprozentig schon mal gemacht. Ich schwöre dir, ich habe den noch nie irgendwo gesehen. Ich schwöre es dir, ich schwöre auf meinen Kampffisch. Auch nicht Joking Rolling. Ich habe den noch nie gehört irgendwo. Ich will mich jetzt noch nicht für Gags rechtfertigen müssen. Nee, es ist ja in Ordnung. Die ich mag, die gut sind und die ich gemacht habe. Der war echt, der war, dass er so schnell war und ohne, ja, also Top, Top-Gag. Der war für mich der perfekte Witz, aber mehr auch nicht. Wollen wir jetzt wieder aufhören an der Stelle? Ja, und der hat gesagt, dass diese zwei Wörter gut gemacht, viel kaputt machen.
Und ich finde es gut, dass er es schafft, diese Wörter zu sagen, lumpi, aber gleichzeitig impliziert, dass er uns noch ein bisschen herantreiben will, dass wir die 110 Prozent geben. Naja, vielleicht, also es gibt ja verschiedene Kategorien, auf denen man einen Podcast bewerten kann, verschiedene Disziplinen. Er sagt sehr lustig, mehr aber auch nicht. Also informativ, nope, keine Ahnung, andere, was gibt es noch für andere Möglichkeiten? Klassisches Beispiel für kaputt analysiert. Ich fand es lustig bis jetzt, weil jetzt stimmt, jetzt einleuchten wir das meinen. Lump, schreib uns mal, welche Podcasts hörst du sonst so? Was gibt es noch für Sphären da draußen, welche Leitern können wir weiter erklimmen? Vor allem, was ich oft höre, dass man uns hört und den Einschlafen-Podcast. Gleichzeitig. Ich glaube, es ist so ein bisschen das Ding.
Einfach einschlafen-Podcast. Gleichzeitig. Ich glaube, es ist so ein bisschen das Ding, die wollen nicht einschlafen, sondern die hören uns, sind total aufgedreht und wollen dann nicht einschlafen, aber um wieder auf das normale Level zu kommen, weil sie den Einschlafen-Podcast. Das finde ich auch ganz gut. So auf einem Ohr, so Upper und auf dem anderen Downer, einfach ein bisschen. Genau, damit die Aussensichtheit. drehen. Die ganze Zeit, wie so ein Boot.
Man ist ein bisschen aufgedreht in der U-Bahn. Kommen wir mal zu unserer ersten Rubrik. Wir müssen tatsächlich heute ein bisschen
durchkommen, weil wir einiges zu tun haben. Ich schick dir mal ganz kurz.
Gott, oh Gott, was ist denn für neue Attitüde hier?
Wir müssen jetzt mal, wir wollen
mehr als das sein.
Die erste Einsendung von Thema
Kindheitstorys, die wir bekommen haben, ist von Henry.
Henry, Entschuldigung.
Henry. Boost. Boost your moderation skills. Und zwar haben wir hier einen Dialog bekommen von Henry. Booster hat so die Anmoderation gehabt. Booster steht uns im Weg. Diese Moderation wurde präsentiert von Booster. Die erste Geschichte von Henry aus dem Lese Lesetagebuch zum kleinen Hobbit, fünfte Klasse. Anscheinend hat Henry in der fünften Klasse. Sorry, ich bin so lustig, dass wir diese Schallendity-Drinks trinken. Und wir haben die ganze Zeit auch, um die es einfach wahnsinnig uns einschränkt. Wir kriegen das nicht mehr bezahlt, wir trinken diese Scheiße freiwillig. Das einzige, was uns beim Moderieren wirklich stören würde, ist Kohlensäure. Das ist eine nette, das ist so, Henry, Henry.
Jedes Mal einfach halb übergeben. Also, Henry hat anscheinend in der fünften Klasse den Hobbit gelesen und es gab dazu einige Hausaufgaben.
Außerdem sollten sie ein Lesetagebuch schreiben und da hat der gute Henry ein fiktives Interview geschrieben. Ja, ganz kurz, wir müssen uns noch mal kurz die Rubrik erklären. Wir lesen Kindergeschichten vor, weil wir finden die, wir haben das letztes vor ein paar Wochen mal gemacht, wir haben Kindergeschichten vorgelesen, weil wir das lustig finden, wie Kinder freidenken, wie sie die Aufgaben, die ihnen gestellt werden, nutzen können, um Funny Stories zu sagen, erzählen. Und deswegen haben wir an euch appelliert, an die Kindheitserinnerungen und Kinderstories. Wir haben hier einen Dialog zwischen der Riesenspinne aus der Hobbit, Kankra glaube ich heisst sie, und einem Interviewer. Dann lese ich mal den Interviewer und du die Riesenspinne. Alles klar. Guten Tag, können Sie mir bitte ein paar Fragen beantworten? Ja. Warum haben Sie die Zwerge und den Hobbit nicht einfach ziehen lassen? Wir hatten Hunger. Warum sind Bilbo, der Hobbit und die Zwerge davongekommen? Sie waren schlauer und der Hobbit war unsichtbar. Was werden Sie nun tun? Auf neue Opfer warten. Dankeschön und auf Wiedersehen. So grossartig. Ein knallhartes Interview, aber eine geile Idee, so den Bösewicht, weil ich glaube, ein Hobbit ist ja, ne, da gibt es ja auch noch diese ganzen Sauron-Vorgänger und so, auf jeden Fall ist die Riesenspinne ein großes Problem, aber einfach diese Riesenspinne, die sich rechtfertigen muss, was man ja immer denkt, so Bösewichte sind ja oft relativ doof in Filmen und einfach so, warum haben sie die Ziele lassen, ja, sie waren schlauer und der Hobbit war unsichtbar, so, ich bin auch nur eine fucking Riesenspinne, ich bin auch nur eine Spine, Leute, was soll ich machen, sorry, denn der ist unsichtbar, der ist ein Zauberer, der ist ein Space Space-Zauberer kommen hier und irgendwelche magischen uralten Ringe. Ich bin eine Riesenspinne, okay? Ich bin im Grunde eine Spinne. Sorry. So lustig aber auch, wie höflich der Interviewer geblieben ist, obwohl er offensichtlich vor einem nicht verurteilten Mörder steht und sagt Dankeschön und auf Wiedersehen. Genau, und was werden Sie nur tun? Auf neue Opfer warten. Alles klar. Dankeschön, auf Wiedersehen, vielen Dank. Ich bin dann auch mal weg. Könnte sogar als Pointe gewertet werden, dass er dann das Interview abbricht, wenn er sagt, auf ein paar. Finde ich super. Kann er das Rute mal malen vielleicht? Apropos Rute, apropos Rute, ups, als hätte ich es mir mal irgendwo aufgeschrieben. Uiuiuiuiui. Ich kam neulich nach Hause in meine Erdgeschosswohnung, in meine lustige Kellerwohnung, Sie haben null neue Nachrichten. Und vor meiner Tür lag ein grosser Umschlag und ich habe es von einer lustigen Comic-Sense-Schrift erkannt, Ralf, Ralle, Rute. Dass du schon lachend am Boden lagst, als du nur die Adresseile gelesen hast, das muss Ruti sein. Ralf Rute hat uns zwei DVDs geschenkt von seinem, na nennen wir es nicht, das wäre Schleibwerbe. Was genau soll der Zuschauer jetzt damit anfangen? Ich übergebe das jetzt im Podcast, damit Leute das haptisch mitbekommen. Was sollen die Hör jetzt mit dieser Information? Die hören die Folie jetzt und so und denken, wow, die übergeben sich offensichtlich was. So, hier kriegst du die Idee. Noch ein bisschen an Folie, musst du ein bisschen einpacken. Ruthie Speed, ein Hoch auf die Wissenschaft. Ui, FSK 6. Und er hat uns diesen tollen Brief, äh, dieses tolle Briefding. Die Leute können das nicht sehen, Stefan. Das ist ja schon klar. Ich beschreibe es deshalb auch. Darauf ist ein Baum, auf dieser Postkarte, da steht einfach, der sagt einfach immer vor einem Date, denkt er. Und ja, das ist lustig, weil auf seiner Nase ein Zweig wächst. Ist wahrscheinlich die Analogie zu einem Pickel. Naja, und er hat uns folgenden tollen Text geschrieben auf seiner Postkarte. Liebe Grüße, Ralf. Das vielen Dank an der Stelle an Ralf Rute für dieses tolle Geschenk, wir haben uns sehr gefreut. Dankeschön. Geil. Danke. Ey, super, ich finde diese Kindergeschichten immer besser. Ich finde diese Idee, die du hattest damals, tolle Idee, die du hattest. Super geil. Und ich finde es auch wirklich eine coole Art, einfach mit dem Lesestoff umzugehen, dass die Kinder da selber Sachen dazu schreiben sollen. Zum Beispiel, er geht's weiter, Tagebucheintrag von Smaug, der schreibt, Liebes Tagebuch, ich, Smaug, werde heute noch zur Stadt im See fliegen und dort alles Leben auslöschen, rrrr, diese haben wahrscheinlich dem sogenannten Meisterdieb und den Zwergen geholfen, Zwerge, rrrr, ich hasse sie, bitte passe auf meinen Schatz auf, liebes Tagebuch, bis bald. PS, ich fliege jetzt los. Erstmal sich seinem Tagebuch vorstellen. Finde ich super gut. Muss der erste Eintrag gewesen sein offensichtlich. Ich glaube, er kam nicht so richtig klar damit, muss man das analysieren. Ja. Ich glaube, er kam nicht so richtig klar damit, dass jetzt Menschen, eine ganze Stadt auslöschen will, alles Leben, finde ich auch eine superile Ausdrucksweise. Ja, ja genau. Und deshalb sich ein Tagebuch angeschafft hat, um das irgendwie zu verarbeiten. PS, ich fliege jetzt los. Ja, auch so gut. Also, ich packe es an, ne? Ciao, mach's gut, ciao. Finde ich grosseinig, einfach vor allem aber auch irgendwie moralisch nicht hundertprozentig rechtfertigt. Ich fliege in die Stadt, um dort alles Leben auszulöschen. Die haben wahrscheinlich. Die haben wahrscheinlich dem sogenannten Meisterdieb geholfen. Und den Zwergen geholfen. Wow, ob das wirklich moralisch ist. Zwerge. Ich hasse sie. Auch gut begründet. Ja, ist doch nicht schlecht. Die finden wir sehr gut. Bitte passe auf meinen Schatz auf, liebes Tagebuch. Finde ich auch sehr gut. Bitte Tagebuch, passe auf meinen Schatz auf. Okay, ich werde mein Bestes geben. Ich bin nur ein Riesentagebuch. ich weiß nicht, was ich machen soll. Die sind von Henry beide. Heisst der wirklich Henry oder ist das ein Künstlername? Nee, Name wurde auf Anraten unserer Rechtsabteilung. Wir könnten kurz vor unserer Rechtsabteilung, oh da ist er ja so. Hallo, ich bin der Anwalt von der Podcast, okay ich gehe wieder. Ja, wir haben noch mehr.
Ne, wir müssen noch ein bisschen durchmischen.
Tatsächlich, wir heben uns hier auch auf und wir werden immer wieder ein paar vorlesen, weil die wirklich fantastisch sind. Noch ein paar Sachen. Florian, schick mir das nebenbei mal bei iMessage, damit wir so ein bisschen hier beide mal mitlesen können. Es ist wirklich toll. Eine Geschichte möchte ich noch vorlesen, die hat mich wirklich sehr berührt. Okay. Und zwar von Sarah. Die schreibt, ihre Geschichte, also ein bisschen ähnlich wie Stefan tatsächlich, du kannst ja noch mal eine von dir vorlesen, eine ähnliche Geschichte wie von Stefan, also eine Erlebniserzählung, was passiert ist. Nochmal Glück gehabt, wie glaube ich 50% aller Geschichten heißen, entweder nochmal Pech gehabt oder nochmal Glück gehabt. Hi, ich bin Lena und ich habe einen Brüder, falsch schon, Entschuldigung, ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt, hi, ich bin Lena und habe einen Bruder und zwei Freundinnen, sie heissen Anna und Katrin, mein Bruder heisst Maximilian, wir sind hier auf der Insel Rügen und verbringen die Sommerferien, Anna, Katrin und ich sitzen gerade am Hafen, wir lesen zusammen spannende Bücher, pötzig packt mich ein starker Mann. Zwei andere Männer haben Anna und Katrin gepackt. Nun kam Maximilian angerannt. Der Mann mit Anna packt jetzt auch noch Maximilian. Nach einer Weile sitzen wir in einem U-Boot und merken, dass die drei Männer das U-Boot mit einer Fernsteuerung losfahren lassen. Wir Mädchen haben alle schreckliche Angst und zittern. Doch Maximilian sagt, macht euch keine Sorgen, Lena, du weisst doch, ich kenne mich mit U-Booten aus. Ja, was sehe ich denn da, ruft Maximilian plötzlich. Was denn, fragen wir Mädchen gespannt. Maximilian antwortet, hier, bei der Steuerung ist ein kleiner Bildschirm, und da sind die Männer, der eine ist auf die Fernbedienung getreten. Super, ruft Katrin, kannst du denn das U-Boot auch steuern, Maximilian? Was denkst du denn? Natürlich, antwortet Maximilian. Na dann, steuer uns doch wieder nach oben, meint Anna. Wird gemacht, murmelt Maximilian. Na endlich, freuen wir uns. Plötzlich steht einer von der Hafenpolizei vor uns und fragt, was macht ihr denn in einem U-Boot, mit dem dürft ihr doch gar nicht fahren, was ist passiert? Wir erzählen es ihnen, sagt Katrin. Auf einmal rennen drei Männer vorbei, Anna und Maximilian erkennen sie als erste, da sind sie, ruft Maximilian, da hat die Polizei die drei Männer auch schon verhaftet. Der Polizist fragt, warum haben sie die Kinder in das U-Boot gesperrt? Darauf antwortet der eine Mann, das war doch nur ein Scherz. Nur ein Scherz? Ich fasse es nicht, ruft Katrin. Und wie heissen Sie, fragt der Polizist. Der erste sagt, ich heisse Mark, der zweite sagt, mein Name ist Ludwig, der dritte antwortet, ich heiße Karl. Da lacht Katrin plötzlich und ruft, sie heißen Quark, Lubelik und Schmarren. Anna, Maximilian und ich lachen. Am Abend haben wir mit unseren Eltern und der Polizei ein Hafenfest gefeiert. Njap nap. Njap nap, nannap, klassische Evox, ein paar Evox waren auch dabei.
Also fantastische Story. Aber geile Geschichte. Aber erstmal gut, die Rollenaufteilung, ganz klar, die Aufgabe der Mädchen ist es, entführt zu werden und zu zittern und Angst zu haben. Maximilian kümmert sich um alles und dann, wie wird der Konflikt gelöst? Der Bösewicht tritt einfach auf die Fernbedienung zum U-Boot und damit kann Maximilian ohne Fernbedienung das U-Boot steuern.
Finde ich auch einfach großartig.
Aber auch klassisch eine Story nur für einen Gag am Ende, damit sie die ganzen Wortspiele machen kann.
Und wir haben tatsächlich auch die Kritik des Lehrers.
Das ist ja geil jetzt.
Und zwar stand da.
Iris, du hattest eine tolle Idee für deine Geschichte.
Denke daran, den Höhepunkt noch mehr auszuschmücken, indem du noch ausführlicher schreibst. Was haben die Kinder im U-Boot zuerst gedacht? Hatten sie Angst? Und als Benotung hat sie bekommen einen Stempel mit einer Katze. Also man weiss nicht ganz genau, ob das jetzt positiv ist oder nicht. Aber vielen Dank Iris für diese fantastische Geschichte mit dem U-Boot. Sehr viel Fantasie, grossartig. Von 2004. Ich weiss nicht, wie alt sie da war. Vor allem nicht so weird wie ich, so komische Ausflüchte, die trotzdem gut ignoriert wurden von der Lehrerin. Irgendwie, aber sie hat das besser beschrieben. Ja, aber auch ganz knall hat die Story nach vorne getrieben und da war auch schon die Polizei, sie wurden verhaftet und am Ende feiern wir mit der Polizei ein Hafenfest, ganz klassisch einfach. Aber auch geil, wie schnell sie im U-Boot waren plötzlich, einfach in so einem hochtechnischen Ding, wo man nicht so ohne ins Reine rein kann. Und vor allem auch die Polizei, das erste, was die Polizei macht, wenn sie die Entführer stellen, so, was macht ihr Kinder denn im U-Boot, ihr dürft doch gar nicht mit dem U-Boot fahren, so. Das ist das Denken eines Kindes, so, ich werde erst bestraft, dass ich in dem U-Boot bin, da darf ich gar nicht sein. Ja genau, so ein Ding muss passieren da einfach in der Welt, da fahre einfach Kinder mit dem U-Boot, hey, ihr sollt das doch nicht machen. Leute, ich hab's euch letzte Woche schon gesagt, raus aus dem U-Boot, Freunde.
Aus dem Jahre 2003 habe ich eine Geschichte, das war auch aus der dritten Klasse.
Da warst du drei Jahre alt?
Ja, eine Weiterführgeschichte, also ich habe einen kleinen Text anfangen bekommen und der ist schon sehr vielversprechend.
Geil, er ist immer nur den Anfang vor. Genau, ich würde den Vorlesen und werde dich dann bitten, ein bisschen dir das Ende auszudenken. Das Märchen vom dicken, fetten Pfannkuchen. Ja, geil. Vielen Dank. Es war einmal ein Koch, der für seinen Herrn Pfannkuchen backen wollte. Sorry, ich fange nochmal an. Es war einmal ein Koch, der für seinen Herrn Pfannkuchen backen wollte. Er nahm Mehl, Milch, Zucker, Butter und ein Ei, rührte alles gut durch und goss es in die Pfanne. Dort ging der Pfannkuchen auf, dass es eine Freude war. Das Küchenmädchen sagte zum Koch, da bekommt unser Herr aber einen schönen, dicken, fetten Pfannkuchen zu essen. Als der Pfannkuchen das hörte, dachte er, was, zum Essen bin ich viel zu schön, da will ich lieber in die weite Welt gehen. Plumps tat er einen Sprung aus der Pfanne auf die Treppe und lief Kantapa-Kantapa zum Haus hinaus. Die Pfanne und den Kochlöffel in der Hand jagten der dicke Koch und das Küchenmädchen hinter ihm her. Erstmal ohne Scheiß, das ist schon so geschrieben, als wären irgendwie so diese Signalwörter, als Kantapper, als es irgendwie untergebringen wurde. Hallodri, Hallodri, Hossassar. Zum Quatsch, okay. Ja, ist so ein sehr langer, würde okay anfangen. Wo ich mir auch dachte, oh Leute, wie man aus diesem Stück Grütze... Der achtjährige Stefan, ach du liebes Wieschen... ...wirft seinen Schal auf seinen Rücken, hinter seinen Rücken, richtet seine Brille und sagt, ach wie soll man aus diesem Grützersten Akt einen noch was Gutes hinkriegen. Drückt seinen Zigarillo aus und sagt, mein Gott, nimmt die Feder zur Hand und sagt, dann schreibe ich euch halt was runter.
Okay, mache ich halt ein Meisterwerk daraus, zauber ich mal was daraus.
Also ich glaube, das ist ein super Anfang. Ich würde jetzt erstmal, er fällt runter in die Wiese, dann wird er von Krähen angegriffen, die ihn natürlich auffressen wollen.
Und er verbündet sich dann mit irgendeinem Tier, mit dem er dann eine Vertrauensbasis aufbaut.
Ja, ich lese euch mal vor.
Ja, okay.
Stefan Tietze, dritte Klasse. Wie alt? Neun. Neun. Doch der Pfannkuchen war nicht langsam, er sprang auf ein Hausdach in den Schornstein herein. Der Koch hatte zum Glück eine Leiter im Restaurant, er holte sie, kletterte aufs Dach und blieb im Schornstein stecken. Klassik. Aber dem Pfannkuchen ging es noch gut. Die Meyers, denen das Haus gehörte, schimpften mit dem Koch und erstatteten eine Anzeige gegen ihn. The Diversion, einfach weg, weg von der Story. Jetzt geht's nur noch darum, die... Es folgte ein langer Rechtsstreit. Genau vor Gericht. Ja, genau. Den Pfannkuchen jedoch bemerkten sie nicht, und er hüpfte ins Waschbecken, wurde nass und das ganze Haus dreckig. Da habe ich ein Wort vergessen, das liegt nicht vor den Rot drüber geschrieben, machte, machte das ganze Haus dreckig. Die Katze Rudi kam zum Pfannkuchen und fragte, wie heisst du? Pfannkuchen, sagte dieser, was, nur Pfannkuchen? Ja, antwortete der Pfannkuchen. Wir müssen dir einen anderen Namen geben. Wie wär's denn mit Rudolf? fragte Rudi. Ja, Rudolf, sagte der Pfannkuchen, und zusammen haben Rudi und Rudolf noch viele Häuser dreckig gemacht. Sehr gut. Ich hab einen ganz eigenen Stil. Willst du nicht genauso heißen wie ich? Man weiss ja nicht wie Rudolf. Mein Name ist ja übrigens Rudolf. Grossartig. Sehr schön. Aber auch super gut. Man merkt einfach, dass du komplett anders denkst. Dass du das Haus gar nicht verlässt, sondern einfach in einem Haus, der Pfannkugel will fliehen, aber verlässt das Haus nicht. Er springt aufs Dach aus irgendeinem Grund, warum, also das ist schon, erfahr mich nicht, ich weiß es nicht, ja schon echt verrückt, ja vor allem auch so Sachen wie Anzeige erstatten, sind glaube ich so Begriffe, die man mal auffasst als Kind und dann, ich war immer jemand, wir sind dann eingefallen, ich musste sie loswerden, ich muss irgendwie diese Anzeige darunter bekommen, weil ich weiß, dass Anzeige erstatten heißt, du hast ja auch selber immer so Aufgaben gestellt, dass du irgendwelche Worte unterbringen musst, die einfach überhaupt nicht reinpassen. Auf jeden Fall. Sehr lustig. Aber genau das meine ich mit diesem irrelevanten Nebensatz. Einfach, dass irgendwelche, das ist genauso wie wenn irgendwie die Action-Verfolgungsjagd fährt und wirft irgendwie den Obstwagen um und dann einfach wird noch erzählt wie der Obstwagen dann noch weiter den Typen verklagt. Das interessiert kein Mensch. Das ist ein langer Rechtsstreit. Kinder sind sehr darunter, die Änderungen sche. Vier Banane auf dem Weissstamm, ja. Und diese Geschichte mit dem Namen Schlittschuhläufer. Wie gut, wie viele von diesen Stories hast du noch? Ich hoffe noch, das ist eine dritte Klasse tatsächlich. Mir fehlt die zweite komplett und die vierte. Ich hoffe, dass ich da noch mal was finde. Prequel und sequel, wie gut ist das denn? Ja, ich glaube, ich habe es nicht gefunden, leider. Es war lustig, meine Eltern waren im Urlaub und der Schrank war leider verschlossen. Und ich habe zum ersten Mal mit einer Büroklammer versucht, etwas aufzubrechen und es ist mir gelungen. Nicht schlecht. Es ist mit einer Büroklammer relativ einfach, Schränke aufzubrechen, so alte. Und was hast du da alles drin gefunden? Ja, fällt mir jetzt kein Gag ein. Okay, muss ja auch nicht sein. Muss ja auch nicht sein. Es ist schon spät.
Okay, muss ja.
4. Februar 2003.
Stefan Tietze, acht Jahre alt.
Schlittschuläufer.
Es lief ein Mann für sein Leben gern Schlittschuh.
Er hiess Herr Jakob.
Diesmal fuhr er durch eine kleine Siedlung.
Er sagte, irgendwie fühle ich mich beobachtet. Und damit hatte er auch Recht. Ein grosser, dicker, glatzköpfiger Mann namens Karl-Heinz beobachtete ihn. Er sass hinterm Fenster. Eine Unverschämtheit auf meinem Grundstück zu fahren, sagte Karl-Heinz. Er ging raus, er wollte Salz streuen, damit Herr Jakob nicht mehr fahren kann. Herr Jakob? Herr Jakob war aus Wasser. Na ja, gut, muss man sich so vorstellen, da ist sehr viel Eis. Ja. So, Herr Jakob fährt da rum in der Siedlung. Ach so, er fährt in der Siedlung Schlittschuh. Er fährt in der Siedlung, ja, das habe ich in so einem kleinen Nebensatz erbindt, mit so einem grossen X, habe ich am Rand. Als es in der Text vom Lektorat zurückkam, hast du dann mal die Korrektur vorgegeben. Habe ich noch kurz das Korrektur an den Rand geschrieben. Ich muss dir das vorstellen, die ganze Siedlung ist vereist. Okay. Ja, ist die Prämisse. Und damit hatte er eine Unverschämtheit auf einem Grundstück zu fahren, sagte Karl-Heinz. Er ging raus, er wollte Salz streuen, damit Herr Jakob nicht mehr fahren kann. Herr Jakob sah Eimer und Schaufel. Karl-Heinz sagte, mach dich vom Acker! Nö, sagte Herr Jakob, doch schliesslich bekam er eine Idee. Er sagte, okay, dann fahr ich halt weg. Tolle Idee. Als er weg war, fing Karl-Heinz sofort an zu streuen, denn er wollte ja Herrn Jakob nicht mehr von seinem Haus sehen. Dann setzte er sich wieder hinter das Fenster und sagte, der kommt so schnell nicht wieder. Doch dann auf einmal kam Herr Jakob auf Rollschuhen angerast und Karl-Heinz war wütend, denn dass Herr Jakob so schlau war, wusste er nicht. Wusste er nicht! Und dann so eine enorm schalante Unterschrift da drunter. So, Meisterberg, dann... Oh, wie cool das das sind! Meisterberg, dann... So eine komplett verschnörkelte Unterschrift. Stefan, sehr, sehr schön. Ey, das müssen wir fast fotografieren, das ist grossartig. Aber auch vor allem diese Anmerkung da oben, das wichtigste Detail, dass er halt durch die Siedlung fährt, weil er überall heiz ist, steht am Rand irgendwo, mit so einem Sternchen. Aber mit kompletten Stolz einfach unten drunter nochmal, Stefan. Meisterberg, ja genau. Mit der Feder. Sehr geil. Ja, coole Story.
Da er so schlau war, wusste er nicht.
Ja, genau.
Dass die Geschichte nicht so schlau ist, wusste ich zu dem Zeitpunkt halt nicht.
Aber sehr gut.
Alter, geil. Ich glaube, das bringt uns noch durch die nächsten zwei Staffeln Podcast-Ufo.
Also wenn ihr darauf keinen Bock mehr habt, tut mir leid, sorry, aber das ist einfach zu gut.
Das sind diese Kindererinnerungen, genau wie Gummibären, Hüpfni und Darm.
Tatsächlich, ich habe auch Geschichten von mir als Kind bekommen,
allerdings habe ich einen Comic gemacht, der nicht so einfach rüberzubringen ist.
Ja, vor allem, wenn er halt weniger beinhalten würde, aber es ist wirklich ein Buch,
es ist wirklich so unfassbar viel. Ja, ich glaube, 17 Seiten. 17 Seiten, die könnten wir alle nacheinander mal veröffentlichen, so jeden Monat, wenn wir so das neue Podcast-Uvo-Comic erschienen. Mein Comic heißt Der, der, also D-E-A, Kampf von F-O-N Max, der Kampf von Max ist der vielversprechende Titel meines Erstlingswerks. Ja, vor allem, es ist wirklich klischeehaft falsch geschrieben. Alle Wörter sind falsch geschrieben. Es gibt teilweise wirklich so Sprechblasen, in denen jedes einzelne Wort falsch geschrieben ist. Aber das finde ich ganz geil, wenn man nicht überlegt, wie Sprache funktioniert. Es soll einfach nach Klang gehen. Man denkt ja immer, dass Deutsch so gesprochen wird, wie man das liest. Ja. Aber jetzt anders als in Englisch, wo es ein TH gibt, was offensichtlich anders gesprochen wird, denkt man, dass Deutsch gesprochen wird, wie es geschrieben wird, aber an deinem geilen Comic sieht man, dass es nicht so ist, dass man das als Kind noch ganz anders wahrnimmt.
Absolut, ich kann mich noch erinnern, als ich in der Schule meine Geschichte schreiben sollte über sein Faschingskostüm, jeder sollte sie verkleiden und dann sollte man eine kleine Geschichte darüber schreiben, was man denn ist und ich bin als Phantom gegangen, also ich hatte eine schwarze Maske und einen schwarzen Umhang um, was unser Badezimmerteppich war, habe ich einfach umgeworfen als Umhang. Und dann wusste ich nicht, wie man Umhang schreibt. Und dann habe ich zur Lehrerin gesagt, Entschuldigung, wie schreibt man mh, wie bitte, mh, wie schreibt man mh von Umhang, weil ich das nicht wusste. Umha, mh um. Aber auch geil, dass es nicht so schade ist zu fragen, wie das Wort geschrieben wird. Ja genau, einfach, Entschuldigen Sie, Frau Riesnig, wie schreibt man um, einfach so. Schon geht's dir gut? Du wurdest auch sehr oft zum Krankenschwester gebracht, ohne Grund. Dann zum Psychiater, dann zum Rechter und dann ach so, NG meinst du.
Aber du kannst
nicht kommunizieren.
Oh mein Gott, was ist Florian, was ist los?
Sehr gut.
Ja, ich kann ein paar Fotos machen und es hochladen.
Ja, oder so Häppchenweise
fand ich ganz lustig, so Episodenweise.
Es gibt tatsächlich von mir auch noch einiges, allerdings ist das alles
halt in meiner Heimat, aber ich werde jetzt über Weihnachten
in die Heimat fahren und da kann ich auch mal ein bisschen was. So gut, wo du gesagt hast, ich habe ein paar Sachen gefunden, aber die sind zu gut. Selbstbewusst, sich nicht der zweiten Ebene, wie man das verstehen kann, bewusst hast du das gesagt. Ich habe hier noch ein paar Storys, da war ich 16, 17, die kannst du auch vorlesen, aber das ist halt einfach lame, weil das ist halt zu gut. Das ist mein Science-Fiction-Roman, der mittlerweile schon mal mehrere Preise gewollt hat. Mehrere Sprachen veröffentlicht worden.
Ja, genau, tatsächlich.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, also schickt uns weiter Geschichten ein und natürlich seid ihr auch immer frei, weiteres Material zu machen.
Ihr könnt Bilder mal, warum mal sage ich das eigentlich jedes Mal, keine Ahnung, ich habe irgendwie so ein bisschen das Bedürfnis zu Community.
Ja, ich weiß schon.
Du schreibst es in die Kommentare, es ist auch zwanghaft, was sich gar nicht juckt, was noch nie wieder aufgegriffen wird.
Es ist wirklich ein bisschen zwanghaft, aber ich freue mich tatsächlich immer, wenn sowas kommt, aber um den zweiten Punkt, wir haben jetzt unseren Shop gelauncht, T-Shirts können jetzt bestellen.
Wir brauchen eine Art und Weise, dass wir, wo ist noch nicht die ganzen T-Shirts?
Lass es.
Aber Stefan, kann man denn nur T-Shirts bestellen? Nein!
Wir haben ein...
Das ist so gut. Der Shop
spiegelt uns ein bisschen wider, wie wir so
ticken. Wir haben ein Logo gemacht,
für euch extra designen lassen,
von unserem Haus- und Hofdesigner
Stefan.
Und zwar haben wir folgendes, wir haben ein Design vorbereitet, wo einfach das Podcast, Keep it das Podcast-Sofo steht, unser Klassiker. Ja, Oldie. Und den haben wir für euch aufbereitet, schön grafisch, leider in Weiss. Mit Vektoren. In Weiss, wir glauben, er ist ein bisschen verpixelt, aber das ist der Style. Das ist tatsächlich ein Punkt, wenn ihr wirklich sicher gehen wollt, wir haben jetzt mal ein paar Probeweise bestellt und werden euch Feedback zur Qualität geben. Wenn ihr die jetzt bestellt, bevor dieses Feedback gekommen ist, kann es sein, dass wenn ihr die bestellt, die einfach mega verpixelt sind und einfach falsch und irgendwie das Logo auf der Innenseite des T-Shirts oder so. Ja, und ein weiteres Problem ist, wie gesagt, weiss, also es sieht auf allen T-Shirts gut aus, außer auf weiss, da sieht es gar nicht aus, weil es nicht da existent ist quasi. Und man kann natürlich nicht ein T-Shirt bestellen, sondern auch Tassen, Schürzen, lustige Stofftiere, Warnwesten, glaube ich, Lampenschirme, Bettdecken, Popschütze. Wenn ihr mal mit dem Podcast-Ufo ins Bett gehen möchtet und euch nachts nicht nur auditiv an uns wecken, sondern auch haptisch, dann habt ihr jetzt ein Kissen. Wir dachten, das wäre eine wahnsinnig gute Idee, wenn wir Tassen verkaufen und so. Nachteil ist, die Tassen sind nur weiss. Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn euch das Podcast-Ufo peinlich ist, ihr uns aber trotzdem unterstützen wollt, kauft einfach die ganzen Sachen in weiss, dann kriegt niemand mit, dass ihr das Podcast-Ufo hört, wir kriegen aber trotzdem richtig Money, Money, Money. Ich frage mich, bedruckt, da habe ich dich schon mal privat gefragt, ich werde es mal öffentlich tun, bedrucken die die weissen Sachen, nicht mit so einem weissen Logo, es ist ein Akrafiker Wein und Blut. Ich glaube, das ist pakistanische Sklavenkinder, das ist scheisseegal, was die auf was drucken müssen. Ja, aber die drucken halt mit ihrer Maschinen, was ja auch Geld kostet, was man nicht sieht. Ja, aber die Leute zahlen ja auch Geld. Die drucken das doch nicht im Vorhinein. Wofür denn? Die drucken das doch erst, wenn sie jemand bestellt hat im App. Ja, genau. Warum drucken die das denn auf Weiss auf Weiss? Ja, weil es jemand will. Weiss auf Weiss, man sieht es nicht. Ja, das ist ihnen doch scheiss egal, solange sie Geld bekommen. Aber die kriegen doch kein Geld, also die drucken ja was umsonst. Warum drucken sie das einfach nicht? Nein, die kriegen Geld, verdammt nochmal, die drucken doch nicht umsonst. Ja, aber die können sich den Druck sparen, will ich damit sagen, weil man es eh nicht sieht. Ich würde als Geschäftsführer sagen, Weiss auf Weiss, nicht mit mir. Mit so einem T-Shirt würde ich rumlaufen. Ja, und tatsächlich, ich finde auch geil,
die Stephans Unterschrift als Achtjähriger, diese selbstbewussteste Unterschrift aller Zeiten auf so ein T-Shirt.
Also Stefan!
Und dann mit so einem Accent, Santigü damals, Stefan!
So schreibt man keinen Namen, nicht so schreibt man.
Aber einfach dieses Selbstbewusstsein als, wie viel alt war, zehn, neun?
Neun.
Was du da weißt?
Und was auch sehr lustig war,
wir als Macher, als
Designer dieses Logos
mussten uns jetzt probeweise was bestellen, um sicher zu gehen,
dass es nicht verpixelt ist. Und Florentin
hat seinen Namen. Florentin hat's
bestellt und eben kam die Bestätigung
an und möchte ich mal
kurz vorlesen, wie die Bestätigung hieß.
Das war,
es war ein bisschen,
ja, ich sag mal, ich bin da immer ein bisschen vorschnell, was sowas angeht. Warte mal. Achtung. Das dauert zu lange. Hallo Will, wir haben deine Ware heute verschickt. Bitte beachten, bla bla, Rechnungsadresse, Will Will, Piepstrasse Piep, Berlin, Deutschland. Ich habe aus Versehen als Vor- und als Nachname Will eingegeben. Will-Will. Will-Will. Was einfach so klingt wie ein bisschen so ein chinesischer Klavierspieler. Ja, genau. Will-Will in Concert. Will-Will und Lang Lang geben heute Gas. Auf der Zeit, wer weiß, ob so nicht bei mir ankommt oder irgendwo in der sibirischen Berge in irgendeiner verschneiten Berghütte sich ein DHL-Mitarbeiter durch die Tundra kämpft, nur um Will-Will sein Päckchen zu übergeben. Um diesen Will-Will, diesen Unmenschen. Will-Will, Will-Will. Willst du nicht noch ein bisschen was von deinem Privatleben erzählen? Wir haben jetzt so wenig von uns selber. Ja, ich habe diese Woche nicht so viel erlebt. Ich habe Brückenschmerzen, seitdem liege ich nur zu Hause und stehe Lecker an. Ja, aber erzähl mal, was ist denn da los? Also du bist sehr gross, hast du Angst, dass du in der Mitte durchbrichst? Ja. Oder was ist deine Angst? Ist es psychosomatisch? Es ist keine Angst. Hier sind Schmerzen. Ich weiß nicht, warum du das auf diese Angstthematik hinaus willst. Nee, es ist ja wahrscheinlich psychosomatisch, weil du bist 17 Jahre alt, du kannst keine Rückenschmerzen haben. Also nicht so, wie du dich hier anstellst jeden Tag. Hatte ich schon mal, und dann bin ich zu so einem billigen Physiotherapeuten gegangen, weil es da, wo ich herkomme, keine guten gibt. Sondern da gibt es so ein komisches, so eine Behindertenwerkstatt, daneben war halt so ein Physiotherapeut. Auch so in grossen Anführungszeichen, Physiotherapeut. Aber nur beim Physio. Und er war so ein bisschen unangenehmer Typ und dann hat er so ein bisschen an mir rumgefuchtelt. Ach, die Schere ausgepackt. Die Schere ausgepackt und danach wirklich, ich steig ins Auto und ich konnte nicht mehr gehen. Der hat es so dramatisch schlimmer gemacht, dann musste ich ins Krankenhaus,
dann musste mir so eine Schmerzinfusion gegeben werden, damit ich wieder gehen konnte.
Und ich glaube, das schleppe ich noch ein bisschen mit mir rum.
So viel zu meinen Problemen. Ich habe jetzt auch ergonomische Schuhe mir mal angezogen.
Am nächsten Wochen bin ich komplett im Rollstuhl und mit meinem Swagway.
Habe ich überlegt heute, wie schlimm ich das fände, im Rollstuhl zu sein. Und dann habe ich nachgedacht. Aber deine Stand-Up-Karriere wird sich wahrscheinlich behindern. Genau, und das, du mieser Wichser, schnell ich raus. Und ich bin zum Schluss gekommen, das ist nur meine Stand-Up-Karriere. Das ist nur meine Stand-Up-Karriere. Das ist nur meine Stand-Up-Karriere. Genau. Apropos Stand-Up. Das ist nur meine Stand-Up-Karriere. Ap. Apropos Stand-Up. Ich sag den Satz nochmal, dass das passt.
Apropos Stand-Up. Und ich bin zu dem Schluss gekommen.
Das ist eigentlich primär bei der Stand-Up-Karriere.
Das ist nur meine Stand-Up-Karriere beeinflusst, ja.
So.
Sehr gut.
Und das Lachen noch drauf ist sehr wichtig.
Also, du schneidest das nicht so.
Forget it, never ever, du kriegst das nicht geschnitten.
Nee, vor allem wenn du das schneidest, ist der Podcast 40 Minuten lang. Das können wir den Leuten nicht antun, das funktioniert nicht. Mir ist aufgefallen, was ich tatsächlich sehr schade finde, dass wir heutzutage keine Klingeltöne mehr haben. Ja, das machen wir gleich beim nächsten Mal. Also, dann bis zum nächsten Mal. Das war das Podcast UFO. Vielen Dank, schicken wir weiter Sachen ein. Und nächste Woche können wir euch von was ganz Besonderem berichten. Ja, oh, freut euch. Nächste Woche wird richtig, richtig gut. Lump, schreibt wieder einen geilen Kommentar und schreibt euch mal an, wer das nächste Mal... Oh, übrigens, wir können ja den Kommentar der Woche mit einem T-Shirt belohnen. Jeden Kommentar der Woche? Ja. Ja, mit welchem Geld eigentlich nochmal? Hä? Wir müssen die auch bezahlen. Nee, das Geld müssen die schon selber zahlen, aber sie kriegen halt ein T-Shirt. Also, seid dabei, wenn ihr es schafft... Sie kriegen einen Link von uns, sie kriegen umsonst einen Link von uns zum Shop.
Ein Gratis-Link, wenn ihr es schafft, den besten Kommentar der Woche zu schreiben, kriegt ihr von uns einen Gratis-Link zu einem T-Shirt, hangt euch rein.
Wir klatschen uns nochmal ab, denn wir sind wieder gegenüber voneinander. Macht's gut!
Und wir heben ab! Terima kasih.